こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さん
痩せてますかはい先日私ですねとある
ダイエット方法をして1ヶ月で体重9kg
落としたっていう動画を出したんですけど
もあれが結構なんかいろんな反響を呼び
まして結構周りの人でもあれ見て
ダイエットしましたって痩せましたって
いう方結構いらっしゃって本当にあの
ありがとうございますいろんな人から実践
して痩せてくれたんですけどもやっぱり中
には私は効果なかったです僕が効果は
なかったですとか
続けられなかったっていう方も
いらっしゃってあのダイエット方法は多分
僕の体には合ってたんですよ
体質的には僕に合ってたから1ヶ月で
9kgっていう結果が出たんですけども
やっぱねなかなか16時間以上何も食べ
ないの毎日するのって結構きついと思うし
続けられないと思うそして体質にもよるか
もしれないと思ったんですけども今回です
ね
僕以外の人でもそれやったら痩せれるのか
どうかっていうのをちょっと実験してみ
たいと思いますというわけで
100キロの形準備しましたどうぞ
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ますパンダさん来ていただきました今日は
よろしくお願いします感激ですありがとう
ございます読んでいただいてパンダさん
はい
体重何kgですか
108kgだと思います108キロ今お
いくつですか今37であのやっぱ代謝も
なんか落ちてくるんですよねはい
僕も29歳なんですけど運動するだけの
痩せなくなってきてちょっとこの方法を
見つけてやってみたらバツンってやって
たっていうことなんでパンダさん的には
痩せたいですかめちゃくちゃ痩せたいです
多分痩せます今回の企画がですね100
キロの人がはじめ社長と同じ生活を100
時間したら何kg痩せるの
[音楽]
よしやっていきたいと思いますというわけ
で今からパンダさんにはですね今日から
100時間僕と生活してもらいます
すごい本当に
辛味とかなかったですよねすごい緊張して
ますお話ししたことは無理なくてすいませ
ん突然来てちょっとこれをきっかけに
仲良くなりましたよろしくお願いします
はいというわけではい
基本的にはなんか僕も多分100時間の中
で
撮影とか
編集とかずっとやってるんですけども普通
に仕事してる時はサンタさんの仕事して
いただいて食事そして
運動
体に取り込んだりなんか痩せるような動き
をする時は一緒に行動してもらいたいなと
思います
基本的には食生活を合わせてもらうと思っ
てて分かりました
オートマジで生活っていう
基本的には何かを食べた後16時間何も
食べない何も飲まないっていう時間を作
るっていう生活を
聞いた話だと23日あれば
食べたものが体に反映されるんですね
[音楽]
あのもしかしたら
途中
厚くなって脱走するかもしれないこの
ダイエットのすごいところってパンダさん
16時間以上待てば
好きなもの食えるんですよえどんなもので
も大丈夫ですただ僕の
オートファジーダイエットちょっと
名前文字ってオートハゼダイエットって
言ってたんですけども16時間以上開けた
後に1時間食い放題っていう
時間はもうパンダさんと僕で相談しちゃっ
て好きなもの同じ力いりましょうか
めちゃくちゃいい
苦しいと思うんですよ絶対16時間もお腹
すかすただ
我慢すれば1時間食い放題が待ってるんで
ちょっと頑張ります
共に最初の1日目2日目は結構苦しいと
思うんですけど
慣れてくると思うんで
すごい不安ですこれそんなことしたこと
ないんですよ今ダイエットされたことあり
ます
ダイエットはしたことあるんすけどもう
本当簡単なやつばっかであなんか泥酔
シャワーを朝に浴びると代謝が4.5倍に
なるっていうやって聞いてやってたとか
ほんと簡単なんしかやってないんですよ駅
歩くとか
パンダさん
違うんですね
食わなければ痩せるんですというわけで
100時間全部と生活するぞー
ちなみにここからも16時間食べれなく
なるんですけども大丈夫ですかもう始まる
始まりますそっか今15時なんですよなの
で
次食べれるのが明日の朝になります
朝に1時間食べるんですかえその後はもう
1時からしたら皆さんね1時間だけです
うわもっと食っときゃよかった今の今立
です
いいんですかありがとうございます
か
いただきます
似合いますねやっぱり100キロ超えると
大変なこととかありますか
寝ても回復しないんですよ
えーなんかやっぱ本当に無呼吸
湯引きとか無呼吸で疲れちゃうみたいな
このままじゃやばいなとは思ってます
要するに命短命なんじゃないかなって
太ってるおじいちゃんいないじゃないです
か
確かにそうですそんなに多くはなくてなん
か怖いなそれって言ったら確かに今回ので
なんか
体感でも覚えてってくれれば
わかりましたなるほどというわけでパンダ
さんはい
心の準備はできましたかできましたいき
ましょうはい
100時間始めしゃちょーと共同生活です
スタート
はいそして何もするわけじゃないんです
けどじゃあまずですね今の体重測っておき
ましょうわかりました
僕から稼いでいただきます
[音楽]
僕の体重
67.45kg行きます
[音楽]
パンダさんの只今の体重
107.3kgです
はいまずで100キロでしたねはい
素晴らしいありがとうございますでも本当
YouTubeぐらいです
太ってて褒められる今までの生活は相当
馬鹿にされて生きて
YouTubeってやっぱり100とか
1000とか1000個とか1万とか
好きなんで100は最高ですもうという
わけでダイエットを始める前の体重僕が
67.45kgパンダさんが17.3kg
のスタートになりますここから100時間
どこまで変われるのか
頑張りましょう頑張りましょう
コンビニ逃げないでくださいね絶対逃げ
ないはい
4遊びに行きましょう行きましょうはい1
時間ほど経ちましたけどもお腹の調子は
どうですか
ポテチプスを食べたんで
全然腹減ってない
あと15時間頑張りましょう本田さんはい
せっかく
スーパーにいるんでなんか
飲み物買ってきましたお願いします
多分お水とかお茶もいいんですけどお腹
最初減ると思うんで
炭酸水っておすすめですめちゃくちゃ好き
なんで
買って帰りましょう
ダメだってパンダさんはいこれが静岡の海
ですよ最高
[音楽]
パンダさん
この時間経過しました
お疲れ様ですどうですかお腹の調子はマジ
で
めちゃくちゃ
減りました
さすがに初日はでもそうですよねただ
ほんと初日は一番きついのとパンダさんで
も明日頑張れば
飯食えるの好きなの
めちゃくちゃきついです
正直
すいません本当に食べても100キロの人
っておデブさんって多分僕と感覚が強いん
ではるかに辛いと思うんですよ僕より
涙出てきてちょっと待って本当に
ありがとうございます
初日はもう辛いと思うんであときつくなっ
たらもう寝るのもまた作戦なんでとか今
ずっと編集してたんですけどももう無理し
てやばかったら言ってくださいありがとう
ございます頑張りましょう
頑張りますよっしゃもう深夜ですね10時
半ぐらいになりました
ちょっとまあ最初の試練ということであの
だいぶ
覚悟しているんでまあまだ耐えれるかな
まだ大丈夫ですかはい夜ご飯抜くことって
あんまりないですよねほぼないですね人生
でちょっと
無実早く寝ましょうねはい
[音楽]
と早めに風呂入って今日寝ましょうはい
というわけで16時間
待てばいいところすいません僕の撮影で中
見て21時間経ってしまいました
どうですかお嫁さん的にはいあのーもう
ほんと限界
限界超えそうです結構きついですか
きついですねあのやっぱ水だけは
飲ませてもらってるんでそれが本当頼りで
チョビチョビ噛みながら飲んで
水ですかはいここからフィーバータイム
ですありがとうございます今日の理想の
動きとしてはお昼ご飯バーと食べます1
時間以内は食べ放題なので
残った時間で
コンビニとか行ってスイーツ食べて最高の
気持ちで
ございますこの
本当何でも食べていいってのはすごいいい
ですねはいただ今回は僕と同じものしか
食べれないので
ですね
お
[音楽]
疲れ様ですよく頑張りましたありがとう
ございます
[拍手]
[音楽]
食べましょういただきます
お腹の
満腹度的には今どれぐらいですか今でも
6割ぐらいは
結構溜まった良かった
デザートいきましょう行きましょうはい
デザート買ってきましたありがとうござい
ますまずは
例えましょう
結構好きですかめちゃくちゃ好きですこれ
がピノかあピノでね
いただきます
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
シェイクの
チョコですチョコパンダさんが
チラッとシェイク飲みたいなって思って
ちょっとデザート僕もう結構好きなんで
多めにとってありがとうございます
こっからさらに16時間頑張りそうですか
今は頑張れ
頑張りましょう
夜中は無理だと思います
はいというわけでもうすぐ1時間終了なん
ですけども最後にプリンタルで終わりまし
たこれが一番好きなプリンですはいお腹の
満腹感的にどうすか今あの8ぐらいですね
8はい8割耐えるソース
僕は今12です
12パンダさん100キロからすると
うわー8割かなでもここ合わせてもらって
最後ですはい
乾杯です乾杯
[音楽]
とかサラダチキンとか絶対ですよそれを
言われてめちゃくちゃ納得しました
心の余裕ができるというかこんな食べれる
からよかった頑張りましょう今回16時間
ちょっといいですか
プリン生まれる
流行ると思うんでやってください
[音楽]
というわけでおデブちゃんとサウナに来
ました
腹減ってますよねさすがに腹減ってますよ
もちろんそろそろ来ると思ったんでサウナ
ってなんか
僕の体感ですけどお腹空いてるの軽減さ
れる気がするんですよそうなんですね
全くわからないですよいい加減して
ください
グッと体疲れさせてパーン寝ては多分
バーンと食べて
[音楽]
あパンダさん30時間経過しました
やりましたどうですかさっきをたくさん
食いましたけど今あのめちゃくちゃ腹減っ
てます
自分のびっくりしてますあんな食べたのに
なんか消化早い気がしますそのたぶんだっ
たんで
早い気もしますけど
はいここを来ないでください
昨日もそう言ってたんですよなんでも今日
もダメなんですか
[音楽]
おやすみ
デブ
[音楽]
はいお昼でございますお昼ですパンナさん
ようやく2足目が食べれるという今日のお
昼は
ラーメンどうですか
ラーメンお願いします
意外と
普通なんだなっていうのはい
[音楽]
意外といけてますだいたい今20時間
ぐらい
[音楽]
いただきます
なんかあの食べた後パワーが裏切ります
元気になりましたよかったです一般のすい
ませんはいもう食えないですなんかこの後
さっきパンダさんとスタバ行ってなんか
甘いののもう寝て話ししてますからはい
ちょっと僕の容量的にちょっとさすがに
大盛りとサマの動画も限界だったんで
多分なしですよね
わかりました大丈夫ですか
大丈夫です明日行きましたはい行き
ましょう
自分もお腹いっぱいなんではい
スタバ部分は残してたんですけど
いただきますいただきます
オートパチ中は
デザートは欠かさず食べてたんでそうなん
ですよねやってらんなくて
ちょっと1回溺れましょうはい
いただきます
[音楽]
50時間経過しました
どうですかパンです
感覚的には
無理そうです何
度も言いますけど人間にはですねはい
交感神経というものがありましてそれ
刺激されると
空腹が紛れるんですよ運動しに行き
ましょう
[音楽]
やめましょう
ダメです
話ししてたんすけど
めっちゃ辛そうです今
もうあのくっつく感じですねお腹空いて
よくあるやつが
ググってなってると
バンドさん
燃えてますそれ
あなたの中の肉が燃えてます今なおパーに
うわストック
[音楽]
クレヨンしんちゃんやねんかいます
70時間が経ちましたはい
どうです
社長そんな悪くないんですけど
サバ系が食べたいとか
欲が出てきましただんだんそば系ですね
いいですか今日は多分またラーメンです
今日です撮影でちょっと滋賀の方に行くん
ですけども
よろしくお願いしますじゃあ行きましょう
はい
[音楽]
一応おすすめの唐揚げでございますはい
デザートです
最高ですジャイアントコーンですね
いただきますいただきます
うまってみましょうここねー
1/4なんでもうほんとラストスパートな
んでさっき食べ終わったと
ジンベイ感終わるなと思ってこんなに一度
の食事で感動するんだと思ったえすごいっ
すよね
毎週毎食結構ねなんて言うんだろうね
[音楽]
というわけで80時間経過しました
用意はしたら実質最終日ということで明日
の夜で
ちょうど100時間どうですか
正直感動してますマジっすかこんなゴー
ルって前でやってこれたんだっていう
気持ちがなんか結構動画がいいのもう
スラスをではあったんですけどちゃんと
我慢してて本当に素晴らしかったですね
常に
監視の方がいらっしゃるんで
食欲と
睡眠欲と
性欲は人暴走させると思ってるんですよ
素晴らしいです
いやそれはそれでもう継続結果なんで
[音楽]
本当食べてないんだよ俺たちは見てるんで
大丈夫ですかはい
別に捕まりましょうはいよろしくお願いし
ます
[音楽]
というわけで90時間経ちましたもう
我々の
共同生活の残り10時間です本当に寂しい
ですね最後ということで
ご褒美ってわけじゃないですけどサウナの
聖地築地さんに
来ております来たかったですはい
すごいワクワクしてます
めっちゃいいんですよここでしっかり整っ
てもらって大したあげてもらってなるほど
最後もうちょっと
少しでも減らせるように
頑張りましょうわかりました
[音楽]
皆さん大変です今企画終了2時間前なん
ですけど
パンですとかいなくなりましたいなかった
でしょいやマジで下にもいなかったです
ちょっと怖いよ大丈夫かな
だからお疲れ様です
お疲れ様です
デブ見ませんでした見てないですよね
中野さん中野さんもまあ
最後にいや待ってでも靴はあるぞ
パンダさん
食材大臣
にいました映ってないですか
食べてないです
食べててほしいみたいなここまで来たら
もう行きましょう
[音楽]
19時になりましたパンダさん100時間
お疲れ様でしたー
やったー
余計やないですかやりましたお疲れ様です
早く食べさせてください
体調測りましょう
はい100時間
ガリと一緒に生活お疲れ様でしたお疲れ様
でした
率直にどうでしたやってみてちょっと
きつかった部分がかなりあったんですけど
でもきつくないと痩せないじゃないですか
減らすもんですからねでプラス
喜びを本当
知れたんで
本当に和食の喜びあと
待つことの喜びあのために頑張るんだって
いう喜びちょっとあったんでちょっと悟っ
た感じになってますか
確かになんか途中からもう
割り切ったっていうか諦めたって言い方が
もう食えないんだみたいな
俺は餌がもらえないんだみたいな
そういう状態になってて
割り切って結構しっかり
真面目に
僕について行ってくださって本当に
助かりましたありがとうございます
ありがとうございますトレーナー販売が気
になる何キロ減ってるかですね
確かにあれ食べて言ってたらっていうのは
ちょっと信じられないですよさっそく
測っていきましょうかはいちょっと僕から
いきますね
僕の100時間前の体重は
67.45kgですはい在荷していただき
ますいきます
着時間後のはじめしゃちょーの体重
ちょっと待って
声怖いやばいやばいやばい
64.4kgです
67.45だったんで3キロです
すごい
暗渠の減った
えだってもうお腹いっぱいぐらいしてたん
ですよなんならきついぐらいだったね
きついぐらいでした
量が多くてきついぐらいだったんですけど
それでこれですよパンダさん
俺に続いてくださいはいこのTシャツの
飲みます
[音楽]
というわけでパンダさんの100時間前の
体重
107.3kgでした
お願いしますいきます
[音楽]
熱い
来ました
104.2kgです
やりました
結果出せましたパンナさん100時間で
マイナス
3.1kgですありがとうございます
すごい要するにこれでわかったのは
これ痩せるんですよたかが100時間で3
キロいってるんで
すごいなぁいや良かったいや
良かったね僕がやってきたことが100
キロのおデブさんでも
同じぐらい体重減るっていうのが証明され
たんでありがとうございます
皆さんこれはおすすめですよ
是非ありがとうございます100時間本当
にありがとう
結果出て良かった
良かった
[音楽]
ベタってした